salut faire des faux billets avec des
vrais billets ça c'est un coup de génie
tellement un coup de génie que les deux
gars qui ont été fait ça ont été cités
dans le livre de Christophe de
Rocancourt pour dire que ça a marqué
même les escrocs petit détail
intéressant ils ont réussi à faire cette
chose impossible qui demanderait un
matériel d'experts dans le pire endroit
du monde avant de commencer bienvenue
dans ce nouvel épisode des dossiers du
Nord des vérités presque nickel oui les
dossiers du Nord VPN sponsorisé par
nordvpn aujourd'hui nous allons
découvrir la vérité sur Jean de La
Fontaine le grand secret qui lui a
permis d'écrire 240 fables parce que
vous le savez tous ce cher Jean mettait
en scène à travers ses fables des
animaux mais ce sont bien des travers
des hommes que la fontaine des peignait
dans celle-ci et pour y arriver il
devait faire des recherches encore et
toujours beaucoup de recherches dans des
livres non que nenni sur son ordinateur
évidemment c'était beaucoup plus rapide
et puis sans risque en utilisant nordvpn
le VPN le plus rapide du marché le plus
simple d'utilisation avec sa connexion
automatique dès que Jeannot devait où je
l'appelle Jeannot dès qu'il devait se
déplacer pour aller se documenter sur
place afin de s'inspirer ne changer son
IP pour se connecter sur des sites des
réservations de tels et profiter de prix
réduit grâce à nordvpn vous avez bien
suivi ah oui et d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote personne ne le sait mais le
fromage dans la fable Le Corbeau et le
renard c'était pas un fromage c'était
une tablette connectée à la base avec
nordvpn dessus une seconde évidemment
puisque avec un seul abonnement vous
pouvez vous connecter à plusieurs de vos
appareils bref si vous cherchez un VPN
alors faites comme cette liste auteur
qui avait cliqué sur le lien dans ma
description pour bénéficier d'une remise
extraordinaire sur tous les abonnements
genre même précisé dans une préface que
si vous étiez pas satisfait en 30 jours
vous seriez remboursé merci Nord VPN et
à bientôt pour une nouvelle vérité
presque nickel oui quoi les pyramides on
remonte à la fin du 19e siècle en 1897
et nous sommes aux États-Unis à
Philadelphie il y a deux jeunes hommes
qui travaillent dans une imprimerie et
ils sont très réputés parce
qu'apparemment très qualifié Baldwin
bretelles et Arthur Taylor alors ces
deux caractères par contre très
différents ils ont tous les deux aux
alentours de 25 ans Baldwin c'est
quelqu'un qui est très énergique qui
prend de la place qui parle fort et qui
est un génie littéral de la mécanique
Arthur lui est un petit peu plus réservé
pas timide mais un peu plus réservé et
c'est un extrêmement bon dessinateur
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a été
engagé ils sont tellement bons dans leur
domaine les deux qui sont considérés par
certains comme les deux meilleurs dans
ce travail-là d'imprimerie aux
États-Unis alors leur travail dans
l'imprimerie c'est pas d'imprimer des
livres c'est de s'occuper de
l'impression des timbres et les timbres
après les billets c'est la chose la plus
complexe à imprimer et la plus délicate
d'ailleurs il existe aussi des histoires
sur des faux timbres qui ont été
fabriqués un jour on va pas en parler
dans cette vidéo mais parce que les
timbres représentent aussi une valeur
mais clairement la fabrication de
billets c'est le Saint Graal c'est le
plus compliqué et le plus complexe on
veut fabriquer des faux billets c'est
pas le dessin c'est pas l'impression
c'est même pas les filigranes ou les
choses qu'on pourrait rajouter
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord le papier
c'est extrêmement sécurisé le papier
de la monnaie alors on pourrait dire il
suffit de décolorer le billet et puis
après de réimprimer au dessus et vous
imaginez bien que je suis pas le premier
à penser à ça tout le monde y a déjà
pensé et personne n'a vraiment réussi à
faire ce qu'il fallait les autorités ont
prévu ça et l'encre est tellement
résistante que c'est impossible de
décolorer entièrement un billet il reste
toujours l'ombre dessin d'origine qui
est en dessous c'est pas propre ça se
voit ça fait jamais un billet blanc
vierge un soir un homme qui s'appelle
William Jacobs invite Arthur et Baldwin
à un dîner un dîner comme ça sans
prétention alors William c'est un
vendeur de cigares il fait un petit peu
d'import-export apparemment je dis
apparemment parce que son CV c'est pas
bon de le mettre noir sur blanc il
trempe toujours dans des affaires quand
même plus ou moins louches et il a pas
mal d'argent à disposition durant le
Guinée il propose à baldwinner Arthur de
tenter l'oeuvre de leur vie de tenter de
fabriquer des faux billets il présente
ça comme étant un peu un challenge alors
j'ai mis puisque ce sont les deux
meilleurs des États-Unis ça pourrait
être incroyable qu'ils essaient de faire
ça pour voir si eux sont vraiment
capables de faire le faux billet parfait
mais il explique que le but c'est pas de
faire ça toute une vie c'est que une
fois que les trois c'était lui et les
deux jeunes hommes auront assez d'argent
ben ils s'arrêtent à ce moment-là ils
prennent tout cela retraite Baldwin est
très séduit par l'idée je pense qu'il
est cette vie déjà par le côté
challengeant de ça et puis par le côté
argent facile après au final ça
fonctionne Arthur bon sans surprise
aimait beaucoup de réserves il est
vraiment pas très d'accord il va en
parler longuement d'ailleurs avec
Baldwin plusieurs fois sur plusieurs
jours et au final il va se laisser
convaincre il va accepter William comme
je vous disais a beaucoup d'argent qui
provient de trucs plus ou moins légaux
et il leur achète un atelier de gravure
pour que les deux puissent commencer par
se mettre à leur compte en effet s'ils
doivent acheter du matériel s'ils
doivent produire s'ils doivent être en
dehors du circuit où tout le monde les
connaît il faut qu'il y ait une raison
valable à ça donc c'est plutôt
intelligent de se dire comme meilleur
couverture possible poulet on leur
montre leur propre gravures imprimerie
évidemment à 25 ans c'est pas simple de
se mettre à son compte mais leur
réputation de est-elle dans tout le pays
qui est assez rapidement ils ont une
clientèle et tant mieux qu'ils aient une
clientèle sa justifie d'autant mieux
tout le matériel qui doit acheter porte
en tenter de fabriquer leur fausse
monnaie alors en termes de préparation
les deux assure grave on dirait une
série Netflix et qui vont à Washington
pour visiter l'endroit où est fabriqué
la monnaie parce qu'on peut faire des
visites ils reviennent tout ils notent
tout ils posent les questions à tout le
monde ils font un travail préparatoire
bien au-delà que examiner un billet ils
reviennent ils se mettent au travail et
Arthur commence à dessiner et il arrive
à dessiner des billets de 100 dollars à
la perfection mais vraiment c'est mieux
qu'une photocopie Baldwin lui de son
côté bosse sur une machine une machine
géniale qu'il arrive à faire tout est
prêt il reste plus qu'à un léger détail
à régler le papier encore une fois il
tente tous les mélanges toutes les
compos toutes les fibres possibles pour
fabriquer du papier mais à chaque fois
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ils veulent
et et William qui finance quand même
tout ça depuis le départ comment c'est
très agacé parce que ça prend du temps
ça prend beaucoup d'argent mais surtout
les papiers que les garçons ont fabriqué
sont déjà largement satisfaisants et
bien supérieur aux faux billets qui qui
parfois déjà circulent c'est-à-dire que
déjà ce qu'ils ont fait est très bien
mais eux sont pas contents et quand
William leur dit mais c'est bon ça passe
tout va bien et bien Baldwin et Arthur
lui remettent dans la tête de non non le
challenge était de créer l'oeuvre de
notre vie de fabriquer les faux billets
parfaits donc on s'arrête pas là les
deux veulent du 100% c'est à dire ils
veulent les faux billets parfaits ou
rien la décoloration de billets je vous
en parlais au début de la vidéo c'est
une solution possible et ils essaient
maintes et maintes fois de décolorer des
billets de 1 dollar pour pas que ça leur
coûte trop cher et puis on se dit que si
on arrive à faire d'un billet de 1
dollar un billet blanc après on
imprimant ce qu'on veut dessus on est
forcément gagnant mais sans surprise il
reste toujours une trace invisible un
léger dessin de visible c'est jamais
tout blanc et c'est là que Baldwin a une
idée de fou l'idée ce serait de découper
les billets en deux alors pas dans ce
sens là pas dans ce sens là mais dans le
sens de la largeur de l'épaisseur du
moins pour réussir à faire deux billets
un qui aurait le recto et rien au milieu
et l'autre quand il y a en milieu et le
Verseau et comme il serait plus fin les
billets ce serait très facile de les
décolorer et ensuite il y aurait juste à
les recoller et imprimer ce qu'on veut
dessus Arthur se dit que c'est
impossible qu'il a déjà des gens conduit
essayé sauf que Baldwin lui dit non mais
moi j'ai trouvé une manière de faire
j'ai une idée pour ça il lui explique il
lui montre et Baldwin arrive vraiment à
découper c'est incroyable un billet en
deux dans le sens de l'épaisseur donc
deux billets
ultra fin sans les abîmer donc il tente
de décolorer leurs deux bouts de billets
ils y arrivent à 100% avec leur mélange
habituel là il y a plus une trace il y a
plus l'ombre d'un dessin il y a plus
rien après bon
commence à avoir peur parce que
maintenant c'est c'est bout de Demi
billet il va falloir les mettre sous une
presse la presse qui va imprimer le
nouveau billet dessus c'est comme ça
qu'on fabrique des billets qu'on imprime
à l'époque donc il se demande si comme
il est fin il sera assez résistant donc
ils font la première partie le premier
dessin sur premier côté et la deuxième
partie et ça fonctionne ça supporte la
presse ce qu'ils impriment dessus c'est
un billet de 100 dollars donc il se
retrouve avec un billet de 100 dollars
en recto blanc derrière il y a un billet
blanc devant et le 100 dollars au verso
donc il faut recoller les deux parties
pour avoir un billet d'épaisseur normal
avec un recto verso il tente plusieurs
cols alors là c'est assez difficile
parce que il faut pas que la colle en
séchant devienne trop rigides si on a un
billet avec un peu cassant un peu rigide
ça va sentir tout de suite ils arrivent
en mélangeant de l'eau et de la poudre
de riz obtenir une colle très résistante
transparente et qui ne durcit pas au
séchage donc qui reste il recolle donc
les deux moitiés fraîchement imprimés il
les laisse sécher et le lendemain
verdict impeccable billet parfait c'est
à dire qu'ils ont pris un billet de 1
dollar ils l'ont transformé en billet de
100 dollars si ils sont aussi nickel que
des vrais je veux dire il doit y avoir
des détails comme les numéros de série
qui collent pas où les trucs comme ça
mais sinon impossible de savoir que
c'est pas un vrai billet surtout que le
papier utilisé c'est le vrai papier quoi
ils partent à la banque avec leur billet
de 100 dollars alors pour vous remettre
dans le contexte si on prend en compte
les années passées l'inflation 100
dollars à l'époque ça vaudrait 3500
dollars aujourd'hui donc ils vont à la
banque pour casser le billet c'est à
dire faire de la monnaie de demander des
billets de 10 dollars ce qui est
complètement pas normal du tout le
banquier se saisit du billet de 100
dollars l'examine sous toutes les
coutures avant de faire la monnaie
évidemment il vérifie c'est pas un faux
billet ça vaut quand même 3500 dollars
encore une fois notre époque il a qu'une
seule conclusion possible il s'agit d'un
vrai billet donc il leur fait la monnaie
des 10 billets de dollars les garçons
repartent avec donc là c'est quand même
terrible ils ont pris un billet de 1 de
dollars ils l'ont transformé en faux
billets de 100 dollars ils sont allés à
la banque ils ont récupéré 100 dollars
de nouveau mais en petite coupure qu'il
a été réelle ils ont même réussi à se
débarrasser du phobie William Jacobs
n'est pas tenu au courant donc un jour
il se pointe à l'imprimerie et il trouve
la prime fermée il se dit que les deux
se sont barrés qu'ils ont peut-être
trouvé comment faire et qui se sont
barrés qui l'ont laissé comme ça en plan
évidemment il va pas se plaindre auprès
de la police donc il laisse tomber et il
s'assoit sur sa thune sur l'argent qu'il
a dépensé mais je vous fais un bon dans
le temps six mois plus tard Trésor
public des États-Unis d'Amérique il y a
un billet qui arrive au Trésor des
États-Unis et l'employé de banque trouve
que le saut du biais est un peu pâle un
peu léger donc il dit je vais le tremper
dans de l'eau chaude pour voir si ça se
décolore il trempe le billet juste dans
l'eau chaude encore une fois juste pour
voir si l'entretient bien si c'est pas
un fake ou un truc comme ça et là il se
passe un truc plus inattendu pour eux
pas dans l'eau chaude le biais
se dédouble parce que oui le mélange
d'eau est de poudre de riz c'est une
colle qui résiste pas à l'eau il suffit
de le tremper un peu dans de l'eau tiède
et tous d'école tout le monde est
prévenu et le chef des services secrets
et en panique parce qu'on ne sait pas
combien de billets de cette qualité sont
en circulation dans le pays ça peut
faire s'effondrer une économie et faire
s'effondrer un pays je vous fais une
petite anecdote rapide mais ça
d'ailleurs été l'un des projets des
Allemands de fabriquer de la fausse
monnaie et en inonder les alliés pour
faire couler leur économie et couler
leur pays il y a des vidéos de Mamie
twink sur le sujet qui existe il y a des
documentaires qui existent je voulais
recommande sur les faux billets
fabriqués par l'Allemagne nazie mais je
reviens à mon chef des services secrets
il prend la seule décision qui peut
prendre à ce moment-là et qui est
incroyable il décide de retirer tous les
billets de 100 dollars en circulation
c'est assez impensable il y en a pour 26
millions de dollars à l'époque
aujourd'hui en valeur marchande ça vaut
milliards de dollars donc lui il décide
de retirer tout ça du marché c'est le
seul moyen en récupérant les vrais et
les faux de pouvoir repartir à neuf en
en mettant à nouveau un circulation au
William Jacob et au courant évidemment
ça veut dire ça ça fait la une de tous
les gens non et pour lui ça veut dire
qu'une seule chose c'est que Baldwin et
Arthur ont bien réussi six mois
auparavant à créer les faux billets de
100 dollars et qui se sont barrés avec
et qu'ils ont inondé le marché et que là
ils sont en train de se faire gauler
mais c'est tellement pas fini comme
histoire William fonce à l'imprimerie de
nouveau celle qu'il avait trouvé fermé
six mois auparavant et il y retrouve
Baldwin et Arthur présent alors la
raison de leur absence c'est qu'ils
étaient juste parti quelques jours dans
le sud pour claquer un peu d'argent et
se faire plaisir et ils avaient pas
prévenu Baldwin on s'envoie pas des SMS
en fin du 19e siècle et quand ils
étaient revenus ils ont plus de
nouvelles de William donc ils sont pas
inquiétants ça discute sec entre Baldwin
Arthur et William ils arrivent à trouver
un compromis d'entente will vous me
fabriquez des nouveaux billets de 100
dollars par rapport au nouveau qui ont
été mis en circulation et vous ne faites
que ça de vos journées voilà et comme ça
moi aussi un moment donné je récupère ma
part sauf que forcément ils auront pas
le temps de faire autre chose donc ça va
attirer l'attention le fait qu'il refuse
des commandes et surtout beaucoup de
commandes encore une fois ils sont
réputés ils ont beaucoup de clients donc
ils font une augmentation générale de
leur tarif mais quand je vous dis une
augmentation c'est prohibitif personne a
envie de payer un imprimeur ce prix là
même les deux meilleures du pays quant
au chef des services secrets il a pas
d'acheter l'affaire lui continue son
enquête il veut savoir qui a fabriqué ça
parce qu'il sait que ça peut revenir à
tout le monde pour lui c'est fait
forcément avec du matériel de
professionnel donc il fait surveiller
toutes les imprimeries et gravures du
secteur jusqu'au jour où il apprend
qu'il y a une imprimerie qui a augmenté
ses tarifs d'une manière démentielle et
elle se trouve à Philadelphie et là pour
lui ça devient intéressant parce que le
faux billets le premier qu'on a emmené
qui s'est au lieu de se décolorer dans
l'eau qui se détachait provenais-tu la
défi aussi donc il envoie toutes ces
équipes là-bas une grosse enquête est
faite on relie Baldwin et Arthur à
William Jacobs du coup il y a plus de
toute la police débarque embarque tout
ce beau monde il passe tous à
l'interrogatoire et et au début les
garçons ni tout en bloc ni tout en bloc
parce que avant que la police rentre ils
ont réussi à planquer les planches les
planches qui servent à fabriquer les
faux billets et ça c'est le nerf de la
guerre donc comme ils ont réussi à
cacher ça pour l'instant il y a pas de
preuve contre eux mais Arthur il est un
peu plus faible psychologiquement et
depuis le début souvenez-vous même dans
la première discussion avec William il
était pas très chaud pour faire ça du
coup il craque il avoue tout il dit même
où sont les planches et quand je vous
dis qu'ils avouent tous c'est que du
coup Baldwin il s'y met aussi donc il
raconte tout il donne toute leur plante
toute leur technique Baldwin va même
aller jusqu'à expliquer comment on peut
découper un billet en deux dans le sens
de l'épaisseur parce que personne
personne aux États-Unis ne sait faire ça
par lui petite parenthèse c'est un
format RST confidentielle
puis vous imaginez bien 1900 il y a
plein de gens qui ont essayé de
répliquer la méthode Baldwin et personne
n'a jamais réussi à le faire
correctement ils sont mis en détention
provisoire avant le jugement leur avocat
les rejoint dans leur cellule parce que
ils ont la même cellule ils ont une
cellules communes il est très énervé il
est très énervé parce que ils ont avoué
où était le matériel et c'est le seul
point de pression en fait que l'avocat
aurait pu avoir ici que la police est
prête et même le gouvernement a négocier
pour récupérer les planches donc ils
auraient pu alléger leur peine mais là
comme ils sont tout donné c'est mort
pour lui il a plus de cartes en main et
il leur explique ça il leur explique
cette grosse bêtise qu'ils ont faite ça
travaille énormément en Baldwin il va y
penser toute la nuit et le lendemain
matin il demande à parler à son avocat
l'avocat ride et Baldwin lui demande de
combien de temps il peut décaler le
procès au maximum et l'avocat lui dit en
utilisant toutes les astuces tous les
recours toutes les ficelles il peut
décaler ça d'un an maximum mais que de
toute manière ça a pas d'intérêt puisque
durant un an ils seront quand même en
détention tous les deux Baldwin lui
demande pas plus d'explications il le
somme de faire ça de décaler le procès
le plus loin possible dans le temps et
lui demande un billet de 20 dollars pour
s'acheter des choses en prison c'est
tout vous l'avez sûrement deviné le
projet de Baldwin c'est pas de s'acheter
des trucs avec 22h en prison c'est un
plus gros projet que ça il veut
fabriquer des faux billets depuis sa
cellule je vous expliquerai quel est
l'intérêt de faire ça juste après c'est
pas juste fabriqué pour fabriquer c'est
encore plus malin que ça sa mère à
Baldwin a bien les voir tous les jours
et c'est une dame très imposante donc
belle green se dit elle pourrait cacher
un petit peu matériel minimum quoi dans
son corset on va dire quelques outils
quelques liquides vraiment juste le
minimum pour essayer de travailler un
petit peu quoi c'est exactement ce
qu'ils font et la nuit Arthur et Baldwin
travail sur les faux billets alors il y
a toujours l'un des deux qui travaillent
et l'autre qui surveille ils alternent
comme ça une nuit sur deux coupez les
billets en deux ça ils savent le faire
il y a pas de problème ils prennent un
billet un dollar il le coupe en deux
décolorez les billets une fois qu'ils
sont séparés en deux aussi il y a pas de
problème maintenant le problème c'est
que pour imprimer il faut du matériel
spécifique il faut faire en premier une
espèce de photographie plus précisément
une photographie et ça ça demande un
matériel volumeeux eux ce qu'ils vont
faire c'est qu'ils vont enduire un
billet de 20 dollars le billet de
l'avocat avec de la gélatine ils vont
laisser sécher ça au soleil toute la
journée on se relayant parce que il faut
pas qu'il y ait l'ombre des barreaux de
la cellule donc ils vont bouger le
billet en fonction de l'orientation du
soleil n'oubliez pas ce sont des génies
si ils font un truc ils veulent le faire
bien à la perfection ensuite gravez la
plaque c'est bon ils ont les quelques
outils qui a ramener sa mère ça suffira
la presse il faut la presse après pour
presser pour recoller les billets pour
presser le dessin ben là ça va aussi ils
ont un petit bloc de fonds d'un kilo 5
qui a été passé par sa mère en quelques
jours ils arrivent à fabriquer 100
billets de 20 dollars qui donnent à la
mère de Baldwin qui va aller les écouler
un petit peu partout une fois que c'est
fait il demande un rendez-vous avec le
et c'est là que le plan de Baldwin se
met en place Baldwin dit au procureur
que oui ils ont trouvé l'imprimerie des
billets de 100 dollars avec les planches
etc mais que je ne sais pas le
gouvernement c'est qu'ils avaient une
deuxième imprimerie où il fabriquait des
billets de 20 dollars et celle-ci ils
l'ont pas trouvé parce que souvenez-vous
vocale aura dit vous avez tout donné au
flics donc on a plus de moyens de
négocier donc là ils inventent un moyen
une imprimerie fantôme quelque part qui
fabrique des billets d'un dollars
d'ailleurs le procureur les croit pas du
tout il se dit justement que c'est un
faux truc pour essayer de négocier donc
les garçons lui disent de vérifier
d'aller dans les banques de Philadelphie
de prendre les billets de 20 dollars et
de vérifier s'il y en a pas d'effort de
la même qualité que leur ancien billet
de 100 dollars le procureur vérifie et
bingo il trouve les faux billets de 20
dollars alors ils sont pas aussi nickel
que les billets de 100 dollars mais on
reconnaît la qualité du travail c'est le
bon papier c'est le vrai papier qui
émane de l'État qui a été décoloré quand
le trempe dans l'eau chaude les billets
sépare c'est la même technique c'est sûr
c'est vous vous dites qui s'en sortent
bien seulement il y a un truc qui va les
trahir c'est ça s'est joué à ça le
billet de 20 dollars le billet d'origine
qui a été recopié dupliqué c'est le
billet qui avait fourni l'avocat et ça
c'est un billet qui était fraîchement
émis c'est-à-dire que des billets il y
en a tous les jours qui rentrent en
circulation et tous les jours des
billets sont aussi détruits et du coup
le numéro de série du billet il indique
que c'est un biais extrêmement récent
tellement récent que ce billet a été
imprimé quand Arthur et Baldwin étaient
déjà en cellule et ça pour le procureur
ça veut dire qu'une chose qui paraît
impossible c'est que les garçons
auraient fabriqués ces faux billets donc
quand même les meilleurs du marché
depuis leur cellule au procès ils ont
tout avoué ils ont tout raconté ils ont
rien cherché à cacher ou à minimiser
donc de l'histoire des billets de 100
dollars jusqu'au billet de 20 dollars
qu'ils ont fait en prison
je pense que ça a tellement bluffé
l'auditoire que du coup leur peine a été
la peine minimale 7 ans pour ce
travail-là pour pour tout ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est assez étonnant c'est une
peine relativement légère quoi je pense
que dans le fond les gens étaient
admiratif un petit peu de cette histoire
là aujourd'hui ils sont considérés comme
les deux plus grands fabricants de
phobies que la terre est portée Baldwin
de son côté est décédé en 1952 une fois
qu'il est sorti le Président il avait
continué sa vie en tant que graveur
Arthur lui est décédé beaucoup plus tôt
dans les années 20 et apparemment il a
jamais supporté cet épisode de la vie
cet épisode en prison c'est quelque
chose qui qui l'a mangé
psychologiquement et même physiquement
et Baldwin sans le savoir jusqu'à son
dernier jour était surveillé par la
police parce que le gouvernement n'avait
qu'une crainte une seule c'est qu'un
jour il dise un faussaire ou à des gens
mal intentionnés un soir ou par exemple
il aurait peut-être vu de dire eh tu
sais comment on coupe un billet en deux
ouais c'est pas compliqué il suffit de
faire ça ça et que ce savoir se diffuse
donc le gouvernement a été plutôt
soulagé d'apprendre en 1952 le décès de
Baldwin qui emporté son secret avec lui
puisque le secret n'avait été révélé
qu'à une infime partie de personnes qui
faisait tous partie des services de
police j'ai supporté cette histoire il y
a une conclusion intéressante c'est
l'admiration que tout le monde a eu pour
eux que peut-être vous avez pour eux
d'ailleurs en écoutant la vidéo et que
les membres du jury est peut-être même
le ou la juge ont eu qui en fait qu'ils
ont eu cette peine légère je pense que
on associe pas vraiment ça un crime
parce que on se sent pas impliqué ou
blessé personnellement et on peut même
pas se projeter dans la personne qui est
lézée parce que c'est pas une personne
c'est un état entier c'est un système
c'est un gouvernement c'est un petit peu
que la même fascination qu'on peut avoir
pour un pour un Lupin pour un Robin des
Bois qui prend en riche pour donner aux
pauvre on n'y voit pas le même justice
en fait directement je pense que c'est
ça qui a joué en leur faveur en fait il
passe au final pour des génies
débrouillards et des personnes
anti-systèmes s'ils avaient volé cet
argent
à des gens comme vous et moi je pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui on aurait cet impact
là sur en fait c'est un peu le même
sentiment que dans la Casa des papel
quoi quand ils vont fabriquer la fausse
monnaie eux-mêmes je pense que ça nous
génère ce même truc dehors ouais ok quoi
anarchiste on y va quoi tu vois sans
prendre en considération les
complications que ça peut amener sur
toutes les économie d'un pays et donc
c'est pas un cadeau non plus pour les
habitants de ce pays vous pouvez faire
ça j'espère que ce nouvel épisode des
all trade des traits anciens des
histoires à la Belle-Mare vous a plu
dites-moi dans les commentaires ça me
ferait extrêmement plaisir merci
beaucoup à vous d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo merci à nordvpn d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo vous avez l'offre incroyable
exclusive dans la description à ce
moment et puis si vous voulez qu'on se
rencontre comme d'habitude à la fin des
spectacles je suis au Palais des Glaces
à Paris jusqu'au 21 décembre tous les
mardis mercredis à 19h30 et après je
suis en tournée jusqu'à fin juin France
- Belgique - Suisse n'hésitez pas à
venir ça fera plaisir de vous voir
prenez soin de vous abonnez-vous à cette
chaîne oui bien sûr à très